[Music]
being able to do this new version of
Thor it's hugely liberating and fun we
had a big set of fat suit which i think
was at a 60 or 70 pounds it was the
hottest I've ever been I mean amazing
and we have obviously the beard the hair
and how these things that go in the
mouth they kind of plump out my cheeks a
bit which sort of had a little effect on
the voice as well but probably in a good
way it was it was a different for a
minute or two years old
the one as God and a lot sugar we're
shooting a superhero film and here's one
of those recognisable superheroes but
he's just turned into a new character
what Chris does with that character and
how it just kind of has this shift his
excitement was really palpable be
playing the character for a while and
really wanted to find something new he
has such dexterity as a talent he's
incredibly funny he's just really lovely
energy is he asleep no no I'm pretty
sure he's dead this is the fight of our
lives we are getting the whole team
right
Oh God it's up regular-sized man hey
guys let's do it
is that everyone you wanted more
are you crying this is my destiny
Avengers Assemble
[Applause]
[Music]
give me that you have the little one
[Music]